فيما يلي ابرز الانشطه والمناصب التي
شغلها الشهداء الثلاثه والبدايه مع الشهيد
جهاد غنام وهو امين وسر المجلس العسكري في
سرايا القدس الذراع العسكري لحركه الجهاد
الاسلاميه وقد شغل العديد من المناصب في
حركه الجهاد منها قياده المنطقه الجنوبيه
في القطاع وتعرض غنام خلال العوامل
الماضيه لمحاوله اغتيال اكثر من مره واصيب
عده مرات حيث بطرت قدماها كما قصف
الاحتلال منزله في حرب عام 2014
واستشهد عدد من اقاربه واتهمه الاحتلال
بالمسؤوليه عن تنسيق وتحويل الاموال
والسلاح بين حركتي الجهاد وحماسه اما خليل
البهتيني فهو عضو المجلس العسكري وقائد
المنطقه الشماليه في سرايا القدس ويبلغ من
العمر 44 عاما تسلم قياده منطقه شمال قطاع
غزه في سرايا القدس بعد اغتيال الشهيد
تيسير الجعبري العام الماضي وتولى مسؤوليه
التصديق على كل العمليات وتنفيذها من
منطقه شمال قطاع غزه يتهمه الجيش
الاسرائيلي بالمسؤوليه عن اطلاق الصواريخ
على مستوطنات غلاف غزه الشهر الماضي
طارق عز الدين وهو احد وقاده العمل
العسكري في الضفه الغربيه ويبلغ من العمر
48 عاما وهو من بلده عرابا جنوب غرب جنينه
لكنه ابعد الى قطاع غزه عام 2011 في اطار
الصفقه التبادل المعروفه باسم وفاء
الاحرار واعتقل اكثر من مره في سجون
الاحتلال اخرها عام 2002 حيث حكم عليه
بالسجن المؤبد اضافه الى 25 عاما اخرى
بتهمه مشاركته فيها هجمات ضد الاحتلال في
الضفه